es el resultado de una excepción
personal y colectiva
asumo tu mapa todo parte de
responsabilidad en esta
y
aquellas
les
expreso mi reconocimiento
incluyendo su apoyo también quiero
agradecer al equipo excepcional de
fidelidad y compromiso que se repartió
por todo el territorio para llevar en
alto nuestras convicciones y nuestros
colores sigo estando persuadida de que
demos nuestro proyecto o el mundio so y
reformador es bueno para francia y para
nuestros compatriotas
en caso de crisis o de inmovilismo en
esta situación hay que poner orden en el
país y hay mucho por reconstruir por eso
la derecha y el centro tan arraigados en
los territorios no deben soltar nada
deben seguir adelante no deben dividirse
no deben renunciar a sus valores y deben
seguir luchando en las legislativas
en una segunda vuelta de la elección
presidencial para poner nuevamente a de
manuel marcos díaz marín de paint esta
noche estoy preocupada por el futuro de
nuestro país
y es que la extrema derecha nunca había
estado tan cerca de un alba al esquivar
el debate democrático
y jugar con los extremos emanuel marco
corrió un buen un buen riesgo y quizás
pagamos el precio
construir mi compromiso político contra
los extremos tanto derecha como la
izquierda siempre los he combatido con
fuerza y con constancia puesto que creo
lo mismo que jacques chirac
que todo en el alma de francia dice que
no a los extremos
el proyecto de marín lópez
conjuraba al país a la discordia a la
impotencia y a la derrota su proximidad
histórica con vladimir putin la
desacredita para de sharp es para
defender los intereses de nuestros
países en esta época trágica
su elección conduciría a borrar a
francia de la escena europea e
internacional
vacío y a pasarlas a pesar de las
profundas divergencias que expresé
durante mi campaña votar en conciencia
por emanuel manu para impedir la llegada
al poder de marín lópez y el caos que
esto les representaría
ya lo dije yo no soy dueña de los
sufragios que se expresaron en el nombre
pero pediré a los electores y electoras
que me honraron con su confianza que
pienso
en las consecuencias desastrosas de
nuestro país y para las generaciones
futuras
de toda elección diferente de la mía que
ellos piensen nacer para la segunda
vuelta
es un tiempo de encuentros en las
ciudades y en los pueblos que hacen la
diversidad y la identidad y belleza en
nuestro país por último quiero decir a
los franceses y a las francesas que los
amo compasión que mi compromiso político
está intacto
lo que para mejorar su vida cotidiana y
sus destinos seguiré luchando y seguiré
luchando con todas mis fuerzas para
servirlos a todos ustedes y para
defender cierta idea de francia viva la
república viva francia